the heart is a pumping engine which from
its earliest appearance in the embryo to
the end of our life
keeps our blood in circulation so that
all our organs may grow and perform
their appointed tasks
few people realize the amount of work
required of the small
mass of muscle
no larger than a man's fist
considered as an engine the heart is
rated as having only about one 240th of
a horsepower
but it is an engine which sometimes
remains in motion for 60
80 or more years without layups repairs
or replacements
you will say that a motor of only one
240th horsepower is not very strong
but the work done by the heart beating
70 times per minute
could in one hour raise the weight of
four tons over a distance of one foot
the energy expanded by the heart in the
course of a whole day
could if he were not in a hurry lift a
person weighing 150 pounds to the very
top of the empire state building
or it could in one day fill a tank
holding 2500 gallons
or about 10 tons of fluid
the heart beats by contracting
rhythmically normally it contracts about
70 times per minute
this amounts to about 100 000 beats in
the course of 24 hours
and nearly 36 million times in a year
could you without tiring perform a
similar task with your hands
more than one hundred thousand times in
one day
how then can the heart without ceasing
and without fatigue
perform its big task over the years of a
lifetime
the answer is that the heart takes a
short rest between each beat
and the rest amounts to about 12 hours
in the course of 24.
during these rest periods the heart
recovers for the next beat
it teaches the lesson that periods of
rest are necessary for sustained
efficiency
without these rest periods the heart
could not execute the 36 million pump
strokes
which are required to keep us alive for
one year
the whole amount of blood in the body is
from five to six quarts
and the heart is the circulating pump
which keeps these five to six quarts
constantly coursing through the body by
way of two circuits of blood vessels
a larger one which leaves the left half
of the heart by way of the aorta
and passes to every part of the body
returning to the right half of the heart
by way of the superior and the inferior
vena cava
and a smaller circuit which leaves the
right half of the heart
by way of the pulmonary arteries to
enter the lungs
where the blood takes up oxygen
and then flows back to the left half of
the heart which it enters by way of the
pulmonary veins
both of these circuits are working
simultaneously
in their course the vessels of both
circuits divide into
smaller and smaller branches the
smallest branches are called capillaries
and are of microscopic size so small
that the tiny blood corpuscles must pass
through them single
file
so enormous is their number that if all
the blood vessels of the body were laid
end to end
they would encircle the globe four times
but their enormous number also accounts
for the fact that it takes about a half
a minute for a given portion of the
blood
to complete its course through the two
circuits thus a single blood cell
may make almost 3 000 round trips in the
course of a single day
the normal heart beats 70 times per
minute on the average
the physician feeling the pulse can
count its frequency and within limits
can draw some conclusions as to the
state of the heart
normally also the pulse rate varies
within fairly large limits
it may drop to 60 or even lower during
sleep may rise to 90 during the morning
shower
remain near seventy during the larger
part of the day
go up above a hundred while taking some
recreational exercise
and drop back to below seventy while
relaxing they're from
such temporary variations are perfectly
normal and to be expected
temporary variations of the heartbeat
may also be due to other causes
such as various forms of excitement
pleasant
or unpleasant such variations may be
very noticeable on even alarming
but they do not indicate an unhealthy
condition of the heart
nor need they be a cause for worry yet
if such occurrences are too frequent or
too persistent
a physical examination is called for
one of the methods available to the
physician for judging the condition of
the heart is by listening to its
rhythmic movements by means of the
stethoscope
the sounds are represented by a subdued
lub dub with a pause of about a half a
second between each double sound
another method of envisioning the
condition of this hidden motor
is by the use of the electrocardiograph
a sensitive instrument
which records the electrical changes
which occur in the heart muscle
during each beat these records are
called electrocardiograms
by a knowledge of the records of normal
hearts a physician draws useful
information
as to the condition of the heart muscle
and the rhythm of the beat
this is a record of a normal heartbeat
this is one of an abnormal beat
every time the heart contracts it forces
a volume of blood into the elastic
arteries
the increased pressure causes their
brief distention
this is noticed as the pulse as you have
seen between heart contractions and its
rest periods
the arteries relax and blood pressure
within decreases
the blood pressure is measured by means
of an apparatus known as the
sphygmomanometer
it is recorded in two phases of the
heart cycle
one when the heart is contracted systole
and one when the heart is relaxed
diastole normal limits of pressure have
been established for both phases
but like the pulse rate blood pressure
may vary
without indicating a condition dangerous
to health
the heart is the strongest organ of our
body yet statistics show that heart
disease has become the most frequent
cause of death
one reason for this is that more people
live to an age
where the effects of wear and tear on
the heart is one of the natural
incidents of life
a normal artery when cut in half
lengthwise shows the normal thickness of
its walls
in arteriosclerosis there occurs a
gradual thickening of the walls
narrowing the channel of the flow the
narrowing of the channels may extend to
the blood vessels
supplying the heart itself
the heart does not lie free in the chest
cavity but is enclosed within a sack
like covering the pericardium
if this sac is removed we see the heart
itself
and the blood vessels that enter and
emerge from it
this large vessel is called the aorta
branching from the aorta where it
emerges from the heart
are two vessels called the coronary
arteries because of their fancied
resemblance to a crown
in a sectional view of the heart wall
the coronary arteries are seen branching
into many thousands of small vessels
they supply the heart muscle with its
necessary food
for strange to say the blood passing
through the chambers of the heart
does not enter the surrounding muscular
structure
a sclerotic narrowing may occur
progressively in the arteries of any
area of the heart
here the coronary arteries are seen in
an enlarged sectional view
these vessels show coronary sclerosis
this heart area supplied by these blood
vessels may not receive enough
nourishment and this may result in a
heart attack so called
in this greatly enlarged cross section
of the heart muscle we see a part of the
affected area
the lessening of the blood supply caused
by coronary sclerosis
causes the muscle to weaken and by a
gradual process to be replaced by scar
tissue
through a number of causes unforeseen or
due to some disease condition
a blood clot within a coronary artery
may cause a complete
and sudden stoppage of the blood supply
causing a sudden and complete stoppage
of function in this part of the heart
muscle
this is called coronary thrombosis while
it may kill the patient suddenly like
the blow of an axe
more frequently he recovers
recovery from coronary thrombosis is
enhanced by a period of complete rest
the chief treatment during which absence
of strain
permits the healing process to proceed
this healing process
consists in the establishment of
so-called collateral circulation
here we see a section of the heart
muscle which has been incapacitated
during the rest period branches from
adjoining unaffected arteries become
larger
and spreading through the affected area
restore it to a greater or lesser degree
of functional capacity
there are other general facts to be
considered overweight for instance
definitely throws additional work upon
the heart its cure and prevention are
possible
an excess of secretion of the thyroid
gland over
stimulates the heart and the circulation
this is called hyperthyroidism
and may be cured or its progress at
least controlled
syphilis is avoidable preventable and
curable
it affects the cardiovascular system
years after the onset
causing a diseased condition of the wall
of the aorta
infections in any part of the body such
as the kidneys
the lungs the nose and throat throw
additional work upon the heart
while all of these are not preventable
or curable
prompt and adequate treatment will
diminish their effects on the heart
luckily your heart is the strongest
organ of your body
it has a tremendous task to perform it
daily pumps nine to ten tons of blood
through miles of blood vessels to keep
your body functioning
help it function properly by following
the rules of good health
and the advice of your family doctor
you